ja und einer von denen die jetzt in
afghanistan festsitzen ist ali wir haben
nach den anschlägen gestern schon mit
ihm gesprochen sein richtiger name ist
nicht ali wir haben ihn geändert um ihn
zu schützen er hat uns sprachaufnahmen
geschickt die seine verzweifelte
situation in der hölle schildern und er
hat vor allem eines angst um seine
schwester
tag gibt es die die lage hier schlimmer
und ich habe auch dreimal versucht nach
flughafen zu gehen und nach stunden
warten und warten da hat leider keine
chance gehabt da reinzugehen da sind
viele menschen die alle raus wurden
einfach ich mache mir öfter sollte nur
meine schwestern weil die taliban so
sagen sie haben einen regen das lädt
alle drei frauen haben und das gilt dann
frauen ab 12 jahre alt ja ich weiß nicht
wie wir von dieser situation raus kommt
den sie dann so was mit meiner
schwestern machen dann ist mein leben
vorbei dann müssen halt auch mit den
kämpfen
oder mit meinem leben spielen
ja ganz schreckliche bilder die wir
gesehen haben und auch eindrücke die uns
ali schildert maxi gibt es ja damit naja
stellt euch vor eure schwester du als
frau mann ist dort zurückgeblieben und
daneben musst du angst haben dass die
taliban die frauen die töchter die
schwestern sich nehmen versklaven mit
denen das machen was eben taliban mit
frauen machen um endlich fürchterliche
vorstellung und das eben was wir dort
zurücklassen das was die beiden dort
zurück lässt das ist die situation in
afghanistan ein mensch der uns im
perfekten deutsche aus hamburg nach
afghanistan gereist schildert dass er
angst hat um seine schwester angst dass
sie eine sex sklaven der taliban werden
könnte und ich glaube eine bittere
bilanz kann es am morgen nach diesen
tödlichen anschlag eigentlich gar nicht
geben als das ist das wie wir dieses
land zurück lassen ich finde auch du
sagst es richtig das macht es so nah war
so deutlich er spricht perfektes deutsch
und erhitzter und hat einfach angst so
kann man sich jetzt auch erst richtig
vorstellen wir haben alle gestern
mehrfach live geschaltet und unser
breaking news er nur wo er noch versucht
hatte zum flughafen zu kommen dann
erzählt es gibt keinen durch ali ist mit
geschlagen worden von den taliban in
einem der checkpoints das zeigt einfach
diese unendliche frustrationen diese
unglaubliche verzweiflung die da vor ort
noch herstellen
[Musik]